late today alberta's premier said the
time has come to live with covid jason
kenney is beginning to lift public
health restrictions what he calls a path
back to normal and he is ending the
proof of vaccine requirement as of
midnight tonight
the threat of covet 19
to public health is no no longer
outweighs
the hugely damaging impact of health
restrictions on our society on people's
mental health on their emotional
well-being on
our broader social health
so now is the time to begin learning to
live with covid
there remain more than fifteen hundred
people with covet in hospital in alberta
our heather urex west is in coots
alberta where protesters resumed a
border blockade heather what are they
telling you tonight
well they've been listening to
the developments from the premier very
closely we know that as you mentioned as
of midnight tonight the proof of vaccine
program will end next week school
children will no longer have to wear
masks to school from there on march 1st
the indoor mask mandate will also be
lifted this is something that protesters
have been asking for but will it be
enough for them to end their their
protest that is now into its second week
likely not the protesters i've spoken
with say they also want to see an end to
federal vaccine mandates
even a change in government
i'm sick of having my kids wear their
masks in school i don't my daughter
breathing carbon monoxide in and out all
day hopefully the mandates get dropped
and then
be nice if trudeau took a flying hike
if he could he could get
get lost
i think he meant carbon dioxide heather
authorities say the blockade is illegal
how are the
rcmp likely to respond
well rcmp told us today that they have
two major objectives here one is to
maintain the peace the other is to
ensure that border access
remains open as well as access to the
local community now at this hour i can
tell you
most of this afternoon that is happening
traffic is getting through the border uh
the mayor of koots says that he does not
want to see
the rcmp take a heavy-handed approach to
protesters adding that many of these
protesters are actually members of the
community
i just mentioned that the people that
are protesting are your neighbor from
down the road and so it's not the kind
of guys that are trying to wreck stuff
and create noise and and pollution and
doing all the stuff that you heard of
other places
and so it requires a different treatment
from the rcmp
still rcmp say there have been illegal
activity at this protest over the past
week they have investigations open and
they say charges will be laid the
alberta government is saying that this
is an illegal protest an illegal
blockade it needs to end
whether that will happen now that the
alberta premier has uh outlined a plan
to lift restrictions provincially that
is something that we will have to wait
and see donna
all right we will heather yorick's west
and coots alberta thank you